[Music]
at the age of 95
and less than three months since the
death of her husband the duke of
edinburgh
the queen is in scotland for her first
major tour since the start of the
pandemic
hollyrood week was cancelled last year
but as proof that life is starting to
return to how it was
the ceremony of the keys was held on the
forecourt of hollyrood palace
with the lord provost welcoming the
queen to her
ancient and hereditary kingdom of
scotland
[Music]
this ancient history 2 in the country's
best-selling soft drink which has been
made in scotland for 120 years iron brew
made in scotland from girders
the queen and her grandson prince
william became the first
royals in living memory to visit the
factory
her majesty was not invited to sample
the product
while prince william admitted it had
passed him by
for the four years he was at university
here when you're at san andreas did you
ever
have an iron berry lots of knowledge but
i've tasted in the jocks
meanwhile the sun shone and a handful of
well-wishers
enjoyed the day i think it's tremendous
that she's here
really that's why we've been here since
10 o'clock waiting for
i think it's great that she's here and
william of course for the queen
the second day of royal week will
include an audience with first minister
nicolas sturgeon
at which her promised referendum might
be expected to get a mention
the palace says the week's activities
will reflect
scotland's rich history and highlight
the pioneering work taking place here
gerard's up sky news edinburgh